Oh mine's always the Ghostface that's  like this Instagram or Facebook  Instagram books or films oh Black  Panther or Wonder Woman I love to pacify  the book I liked Michael B Jordan who is  neither of this yeah he was a handsome  villain a bad guy but boy he was so good  wine or beer watch Elsa  okay burger or pizza burger hugs or  kisses kisses snow white or Prince  Charming no white one of the Seven  Dwarves maybe most used emoji oh the guy  that's like this with the 100 mine's  always the Ghostface that's like this  mine's a dancey girl in the red dress  dancing girl Sun or moon moon beach or  pool each that's her dog's dog  stilettos or sneakers sneakers tattoos  well Papa Arne be our name coffee or tea  puffy teeth traveled to the future or  the past  teacher pasture I thought those were